britney spears is standing up for
herself oh yeah the 39 year old singer
took to instagram on monday to address
pregnancy and breast augmentation rumors
and explain why she's comfortable
bearing some skin from time to time it's
fun for me brit shared these snaps
standing topless in some white underwear
alongside a lengthy caption that read in
part quote no guys i didn't get a boob
job in just a week nor am i pregnant i
have boobs in these pigs because i
devoured food
[Music]
the toxic singer continued calling the
response to her sexy pics quote quite
twisted when women are hot and they want
to shed a layer breit goes on to talk
about how she felt self-conscious in the
past but feels more comfortable in her
skin now
quote it's because i was born into this
world naked and i honestly feel like the
weight of the world has been on my
shoulders and it's made me view myself
that way
that weight of the world comment is most
likely in reference to her ongoing
conservatorship battle which took a turn
earlier this month when her dad jamie
spears agreed to step down as
conservator of her estate when the time
is right
a decision her mother lin spears
supports
okay so i'm sure a lot of you guys are
wondering how i'm doing i do want to let
you guys know things are way better than
what i ever anticipated
what he's doing is saying yes yes
i will step down no problem i'm after
the best interests of my daughter
however i'm not going to do it right
away we first need to meet and discuss
things and figure things out so it
definitely is not a immediate victory
for britney spears it's a good step in
the right direction however
in the caption of brit's post she said
that everything she's been through made
her want to see herself in a lighter way
naked like the way she was born quote i
am a woman a beautiful sensitive woman
who needs to look at myself in my purest
form
the superstar adds that she's not going
to do topless pics for the rest of her
life because it would get boring but
noted that posing that way sure as hell
helps when you need to be enlightened
it's really kind of exciting brit also
referenced the ongoing fan movement to
get her out of her conservatorship
writing quote i will admit the free
britney comments after i took my shirt
off were actually really [ __ ] funny
and she concluded her post noting that
there's a way deeper meaning to the free
britney movement than you can ever
imagine before thanking her fans for
being so damn amazing
[Applause]